I'm so thrilled you would come here
thank you are you kidding I grew up
watching your movies I love it
out right now at midnight which we're
going to get into in a minute but
Rock of Ages with
I mean I freak out for Tom Cruise but is
it true that you do an impression of Tom
yeah yes will you do one please
true
listen to me
you
pleat
[Applause]
you worship him on Rock of Ages and I
was studying the fact that like you guys
had to play guitar yeah you know it was
crazy so uh it was the table read and I
thought it was going to be a small table
read
because that you know Rock of Ages was
my first movie and they asked me
and uh the prop Master asks me hey David
do you want to play guitar at the table
read and I just learned how to play
guitar okay and I go yeah sure Chris
yeah yeah yeah for sure and I walk in
and it's a room with a hundred people
microphones they're like we want you to
sing all the songs it was like a show
and tell and then I look over my left my
left shoulder and Tom walks out in
character after being in the chair for
four hours as Stacy Jazz that's Stacy
Jacks tattoos shirtless the band behind
him I look over my right shoulder and
Alec Baldwin is so nervous he can't even
highlight his own lines and I'm just
going yeah for sure I'm gonna get fired
so the time comes and I play Don't Stop
Believing and Tom who's sitting two
chairs to my right stands up he's like
you're learning how to play guitar I'm
learning how to play guitar from the
same coach let's do jamming sessions
and I'm thinking yeah sure yeah yeah of
course yeah let's do jamming sessions
that night he calls me up I'm watching
Game of Thrones unknown number it's like
Diego it's Tom
jamming sessions come up to my penthouse
and then after he's like look man
here's everything I wish I knew when I
was 20 years old if it's cool with you
and only if you're cool with it like you
know I'd love to tell you what I learned
from Newman and Dustin Hoffman and and
I'm just going like what are you kidding
me like yeah yeah and I you know for
like a week we would have jamming
sessions he was like let's just call
them jamming sessions no one needs to
know about this and he like mentored me
like throughout the whole movie well
that's why we love Tom Curtis
yeah all right you you start in this
wonderful new rom-com at midnight
um and I've been watching it and well we
have a clip so let's take a look
together
it's the cute guy who saw you naked but
I I did not see her naked and now I've
heard everything
I thought it was your day off
uh yeah well it was but I was called in
for a last minute meeting for a
committee that I oversee and um
I'm an overachiever
well it's good to see you
see you
okay I feel like I could totally set up
what this movie is about but I also
realized that you you are here so will
you tell us what this movie is about the
movie is about Sophie Wilder played by
Monica Barbara who's in top gun too and
killed it yep that's right and she's an
act dress
yeah and she's a big actress huge movie
star big movie star shooting a superhero
movie uh and her boyfriend of like five
years five years uh cheats on her but
they have to pretend to still be
together because they're like the
hollywooded couple right for marketing
purposes and to promote the movie and
then they go to Mexico to finish
shooting the movie the Riviera Maya
close to Cancun and Tulum and all these
beautiful beaches and uh they all go and
stay in this hotel and she meets
Alejandro played by me who's a junior
Hotel manager and after that we can only
meet at midnight because I can't get
caught running around with a hotel guest
nor can she and she can't get caught and
also I wanted it to be a love letter to
Mexico I'm from Mexico City and I feel
like you know most of the stories coming
out of Mexico have to do with narcos and
drugs and it's a sad reality but it's
not everything that we have to offer I
know
and speaking of is it true you speak
Spanish and Portuguese
um so will you take us out in this clip
would you prefer to do it in Spanish or
Portuguese I love both I'll do it in in
Portuguese it's my favorite
no Paramount plus pesos
[Applause]
for coming here thank you so much
[Music]